joining me now are Brian and Samantha
Scott residents of East Palestine Ohio
Brian
um what did it mean for you today
to know that President Trump showed up
he made sure that supplies arrived
but President Biden still has not
uh you know a lot of people have been
walking around town with their heads
full of doubt and fear and feeling
neglected
and I feel like Trump's presence today
uh helped reassure them that
you know they do care they have not been
forgotten about and uh it definitely
helped lift the spirits and give people
some peace of mind
uh knowing that
people know who we are and what's going
on around here
and uh well you know with
a president not showing up it kind of
did the opposite and that was that's
what was causing a lot of the neglect
and the feelings of doubt and fear
well I want to go to your wife next to
you Mrs Scott because when when you
think about when you think about
the delay and even acknowledging
what happened
I mean it was almost like a kind of a
casual dismissal of this
uh just just knowing that so it
definitely feels
it definitely felt like a bold move for
him to go to Ukraine while we have all
of this going on here
um I I do just want to add one thing if
I could um you know as a small town we
have really rallied together with the
help and support of other local towns in
our area but the moment we let the Focus
Shift to the political aspect I feel we
lose our voice as a community
um
and we don't need that right now so we
are stronger together and division is
not going to help us get the justice
that our town deserves that our
residents deserve our agriculture our
personal health not just now but years
to come well Brian I understand Samantha
and Samantha's view that look politics
is is nasty I I get it better than
anyone believe me I empathize with that
however you do need government help
and everyone rallying together is a
beautiful thing Brian but
when the EPA administrator is urging
residents to trust the science first I
want you to watch this and then react on
the other side
I'm not second-guessing their
experiences what I can say is the water
that has been tested and the air that
has been tested is coming back with no
adverse health impact levels and so we
can provide the data I trust the data I
trust the science
well Brian a lot of people reacting
online tonight are saying well we
trusted the data on covet as well about
closing the schools and so much of the
other things that we were told at the
time and that turned out not to be true
and so who do you trust now Brian
whom do you trust I think that's where a
lot of the doubt comes from and uh you
know consequence consequently it's
resulting in the fear you know if we've
learned anything over the past few years
is that we've been lied to so much we've
been told half truths very often
and now it comes to the point where when
you do hear something
what do you believe and what do you not
believe and I think that doubt is what's
filling people with fear we don't know
who to believe what to believe and then
that's when our safety feels at risk
well and Samantha I think that is the
point we want our politicians of both
parties to just give us the facts right
and then we can make decisions based on
the facts that we know but when the
facts are skewed or kind of dismissed
because they're inconvenient that's what
hurts people and it hurts public trust
more than anything else at times like
this you need to trust somebody
right absolutely
and Samantha right now what is your
message to secretary budage who will be
after these weeks on scene there
um
I need to be cautious with with what I
say I don't want to paint my town in a
in a poor image but
you know just a message
right Samantha it's not it's not a I'm
not asking you to be pejorative but he's
going to be there and it's a listening
tour of sorts so maybe Brian do you have
a message for him he wants to listen
come on come on down you know we're um
you don't need to be in fear of your
safety
uh we're not a mean town no we we need
we need our people who represent us to
come down show your face give us your
plan of action show us that you care
yeah make some changes and
um you know just do your job show up
that's pretty simple do your job and
show up everybody needs to hear that
tonight Brian and Samantha great to see
both of you we're staying on this story
thank you so much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else